morning Hank it's Tuesday May 28 2013
you know something just occurred to me I
probably said good morning Hank it's
Tuesday like 600 times in my life and I
only just now realized that Tuesday is
probably because it's the second day
nope
in fact it is named for to the
proto-germanic God of War
Hank today's video comes in three parts
part 1 a quick response to your video
about tumblr and startups and the
monetization of cool things I think the
underlying problem is that almost
everything on the Internet is dependent
upon advertising and advertisers in my
opinion are terrible at measuring the
value in the creator viewer relationship
I think advertisers care much more about
the number of views than the quality of
views so for instance thoughts from
places videos are consistently the least
viewed videos on the blog brother's
channel so the advertising revenue model
tells us to stop making thoughts from
places videos and focus on like giraffe
sex but in fact tank we know from
comments and conversations with
nerdfighters that thoughts from places
videos are among their favorites the
people we really want to love our videos
love those videos dare I say it more
than giraffe sex tank don't get me wrong
I dig giraffe sex but I want a broader
Internet and I worry that Tumblr and
Facebook and even YouTube can only
support that breadth as long as they are
willing to lose money so hey please fix
this problem during my paternity leave
okay thanks mark to nerd factor thank
you so much to the more than 1,600
people who posted videos to the nerd
factor competition I am very sad that I
can only be replaced by two of you but
to quote to the great proto-germanic god
of war there must always be a victor
it's not really a quote so our first
winner is magic turtle 643 check out
this teacup I got look when it comes to
it and what's this supposed to be a
checklist tea tea tea well check check
check
hmm oh man nothing in there look they
both have the same drowsy bear in a
nightgown and this is my personal
favorite the instant chrysanthemum
beverage no not sure if this is actually
tea or not and I have to be honest I
haven't actually tried this one because
I'm pretty sure there was a packaging
error and instead of a chrysanthemum
beverage I wound up with packets of
Chinese rat poison peg this guy's been
making videos for more than five years
he's participated in the project for
awesome and he has fewer than 700
subscribers and he's hilarious so let's
change that so he will be playing the
role of me on some forthcoming Tuesday
of my paternity leave as will nerdy and
quirky hello welcome to nerdyandquirky
as a force
Keeney rolled with the emotional
maturity of say another potato I feel
like it's my responsibility to tell you
all how to attract human with romantic
undertones because Valentine's Day nerdy
and quirky is one of the best youtubers
I have come across in years take a
gander at this clip from her video about
fangirls you may also find your fangirl
in tears do not approach this is their
most dangerous state when they are prone
to lash out take care of them from a
distance there their fangirl the new
season starts next fall unless it's from
NBC so it goes of the two nerdfighters
who will be standing in for me during my
paternity leave however I wanted to
clear two more winners South's singers
first Ruby day
love sky above the horizon
oh man that is good and second the SWOT
sisters I am a very model of a
nerdfighter a collection of information
epic awesome literary and absurd I play
Dungeons and Dragons and I quote the
Ducks historical from William Hartnell
to Matt Smith in order categorical the
whole song is amazing there are links to
all these channels in the doobly-doo
they are all excellent so please check
them out and subscribe to them thank you
to everyone who submitted to nerd Factor
and especially to Danica who helped make
all of this possible and now part three
Thank You member that special edition
tip us audiobook narrated by me with
like a bonus DVD and stuff was available
for a while at dftba.com it is back
available for pre-order now link in the
doobly-doo where you can just click
there Hank I will see you on Friday
little known fact named for Stephen Fry